[Music]
[Applause]
hi my name is Jennifer Cheung and I'm
one of the founders of Lanier we're an
independent design studio making
minimalist high quality leather bags and
watches my partner Roman and I got our
start three years ago in 2014 when we
launched our first collection of men's
bags on IndieGoGo the crowdfunding
platform with the help of more than 500
guys total strangers from around the
world we were able to raise $150,000 in
funding which was essentially $150,000
of pre-orders and with that we were able
to start production after that Roman and
I took turns working full-time on linear
with the other person working a
full-time job so that we could keep a
roof over our heads until we knew our
business had legs today we're still
proudly bootstrapped
and we're a tiny team is just the two of
us and we have three remote team members
and we're on track to do more than ten
million dollars in sales this year
selling only online now I know that many
people think that my life seems really
glamorous charmed even I get to work
with my partner I get to live in
Florence Italy I get to design beautiful
products I get to bring a creative
vision into reality that's pretty cool
but today I want to show you that my
life is not so glamorous at all I want
to show you the ugly side and I think
this is so important to talk about
because we live in a world of
sensational headlines and Instagram and
I think it's so easy to look at somebody
else's story from afar and think man she
has it so easy I think this kind of
attitude is especially dangerous if
you're an entrepreneur or if you plan to
start your own business one day because
it creates really unrealistic
expectations of yourself and if what
your entrepreneurial journey will look
like so tonight I'm going to tell you
about a particular low point that I've
experienced and when I say low point
that's a huge understatement because
these were truly terrifying a few weeks
of my life this was January 2016 and
Roman and I had lon
a collection of women's bags on
Kickstarter a few months before we were
going to China to our factory to do our
final quality control before sending out
thousands of parcels all around the
world now when we arrived at the factory
we were astounded to discover that there
was something a little off with the
leather of one of our bags the soft tote
that meant that the factory had received
the leather a few months before had seen
that it didn't quite match the sample
decided not to tell us and then
proceeded to make backs with them and we
were finding out at the eleventh hour
now we had 350 women who had kind of
pre-ordered the bag a few months before
and they were waiting for this bag and
we knew that a lot of them might not
have noticed a difference because
they've never seen the sample in real
life but we were adamant that we were
not going to send out a single bag that
was anything less than perfect so we
went to the factory owner to try to find
a solution and he reacted really badly
he refused to admit that they'd made a
mistake in fact he put a metaphorical
gun to her head
he said you either take everything and
pay for everything including the
defective bags or you leave it all here
now the factory was already one month
late with production and they were just
about to close for three weeks for
Chinese New Year we decided to take a
calculated risk we had thousands of
other parcels that needed to go out with
good bags and we didn't want to risk the
factory keeping them over Chinese New
Year and so we knowingly spent tens of
thousands of dollars on defective
merchandise to ensure that the factory
released our goods we were taking a
gamble that we would be able to reason
with a factory owner later on but deep
down inside we knew we were in big
trouble there was no way we could
continue to work with this guy and so we
booked it to Italy now in Italy we had
four goals the first was we had to find
a new tannery because we no longer
trusted the tannery that had made the
bad leather in the first place second we
had to find a new factory third we had
to send out thousands of parts
for all the backers and customers who'd
been waiting and forth we had to break
the news to the 350 people who were
waiting for the soft oats now things
started to go downhill pretty quickly
our fulfillment partner lost control
over the warehouse that they
subcontracted and while they were
supposed to send out thousands of
parcels after 5 days by day 5 they had
only sent out 26 now we were staying in
a tiny crappy Airbnb in Florence with no
heat and we would wake up at 2:00 in the
morning so that we could be awake when
the warehouse staff woke up and we would
call them and try to get control of the
situation and then we would go to sleep
at 4:00 a.m. we'd wake up again at 6:30
and start calling 350 people who were
waiting for the totes Roman and I
personally called each and every single
one of them we had to explain to them
that there was a problem we were trying
to remake the totes but we weren't quite
sure when they would be ready not a fun
conversation to have that was all before
8:30 in the morning at 8:30 we would get
in our rental car drive out of the city
and meet with a bunch of suppliers
tanneries and factories over lunchtime
we tried to take a nap in our car
somewhere and then over the afternoon we
would have back-to-back meetings trying
to find the tannery in the factory who
could help us solve this problem we
drive home at 6:00 and then it was time
for more phone calls this time to her
backers and customers in the Western
Hemisphere after a few more hours of
phone calls we would open our inboxes
and have to deal with the hundreds of
emails coming in from anxious people
wondering where their parcels were we'd
go to sleep at midnight wake up at 2:00
and so on and so on we did this for
three weeks we had so little money in
the bank we were freezing our tails off
in this Airbnb and there was not a night
that we slept more than four hours in a
row and all this time we had this
ominous feeling that everything that we
had worked so hard to build over the
last year and a half would just come
crumbling
down around us well it didn't come
crumbling down
and bit by bit we had small
breakthroughs and we were slowly able to
write the
we found a tannery we found a factory we
started making the replacement totes
we finally solved our fulfillment
problem by calling their investors and
most of the 350 people that we called up
were really kind and understanding best
of all when we finally sent out the
totes five months later they were
delighted but it was only two months
later that we finally felt that we had
crawled ourselves out of this deep dark
hole and were finally on solid ground
again and that was when we launched a
Kickstarter campaign for our new watch
collection amazingly that Kickstarter
campaign raised a million dollars and
was only then when we saw that million
dollars on her campaign page that we've
breathed the sigh of relief and thought
that we were able to keep moving on now
many people wrote to me around that time
marveling at the Kickstarter campaign oh
my gosh and 1 million dollar campaign
that's incredible that's an overnight
success well now that you know what we
went through in the months leading up to
that you'll know that it was not an
overnight success
it certainly wasn't very glamorous and
it wasn't very fun at all we had gone
through months of despair we had gone
and cheated out of half a year of my
salary and we'd been on the verge of
bankruptcy the thing is entrepreneurship
is a crazy incredible ride but it's
messy it's unpredictable and it will
squeeze you of everything that you've
got the reality is you're going to fall
on your face over and over again I keep
falling on my face and I know it's not
going to stop but it's in those moments
when you feel like you've fallen on your
face that you get to show the universe
what you're made of you pick yourself up
you dust yourself off
and you keep putting one foot in front
of the other that is what real
entrepreneurship looks like not some
splashy headline or some carefully
curated Instagram account so don't be
fooled by mine and be ready for a fight
best of luck over there ventures
[Applause]
[Music]